on this episode my father-in-law comes
on to hock his book
[Music]
you ask
and I am
this is
ask Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 153 of
the ask gary vee show as you can see in
a rare situation by the way we're doing
a doubleheader today we're doing a
doubleheader today Peter I'll introduce
Peter in a second we're doing a
doubleheader today so that's the first
time we've ever done that so I like the
fact that he rock and Stefan are both
gonna actually have to work India that's
good for a change right and we'll be
editing it up and I'm excited you guys
good I guess we can release them very
similar at the same time I'm excited
about that but Peter why don't you tell
the Vayner nation who you are
hello everybody Peter Klein and yes I
really am gary vaynerchuk's
father-in-law it's true in this episode
I'm glad to say we're going to reverse
the roles a bit and we're going to
reverse carry into moving from mr.
answer man to mr. question man
okay and before do you know this India
okay good here we go well you got to be
flexible in our business yep and before
we yes Gary to maybe ask a couple
questions of why I'm really here sitting
in on this version I want to ask Gary a
maybe a bit of an introspective question
building on a question asked by Mark
Cuban my episode 151 and a half yeah so
I might be a Kurd or not 150 and a half
when he wanted to know and he I think he
basically asked Gary Gary when you
interview yes talent yes it would have
you with a key question yes he asked it
almost every interview yes so my
question to you Gary has really three
parts the first two pretty fast in your
history yes from a kid on yes through
today yes
was there ever an individual guy or gal
yes who you think intensely disliked you
I did yes or no that knew yes sir
and I would use the word almost 8 but
I'd go short of that intensely - or you
think dislike you that knew me for more
than a second or just came across me
well the answer is a ton of people
okay okay second part of it is um give
me the name of one of them just hires
name alone so first Oded O'Day Oded Oded
OD IDI Oded Oded Oded Oded Gary's not
here okay
what do you dislike with Gary Oh Peter
here's the thing and so we're in second
grade and Gary's very popular and
everybody likes him and that bothers me
so I'm not going to invite him to his
birthday party unto my birthday party
because I'm Oded because I'm jealous of
his enormous charisma okay well my
follow-up to that was basically going to
be that you scored fine on that question
on passion and transparency yes I'm not
quite sure in the transparency side well
I think that's a trick but if it's like
so truth an introspective lies that's
right Peter Holland I'm gonna jump in
here guys I adore my father let me tell
you a fun fact Peter why don't you
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna play a
little bit here as hosts here's a little
fun fact this is gonna blow a lot of
people's minds that way what you know
you were a tremendously successful
marketer and you once were involved in
the naming rights of a football stadium
when you were an executive true true why
don't you tell the Vayner nation
what stadium that was Gillette Stadium
New England Patriots a couple of us went
there in very early oh one can you
believe this so no we still made the I
still made the cut to get on the
askgaryvee show and the headline was we
didn't even know there was a stadium
being built at the time of doing it
working on a turnaround Gillette company
and maybe a year into the turnaround the
Kraft family approached us actually a
software company CMG I I think may have
gone foundered under an $80 a share down
to five or ten because they had bought
rights to the new stadium and before the
stadium opened they wanted out so I
could make a long story short we were
able to the naming rights to Gillette
Stadium
so vaynernation you probably will find a
super fascinating Peter you know I when
I met Peter's lovely daughter Lizzie
I was very much in the wine business
peter was actively the top one of the
top executives at Gillette Peter didn't
you guys like didn't the deal of selling
Gillette fall through on the night of
our wedding um there's some funny story
like that that's right
it originally is that why you've missed
the whole wedding was that no that was
public domain I go you know is probably
big guy sorry to decide to walk for a
few reasons and then they revisited
about 4-6 weeks later that must have
five that was one of the that was the
best day of your life right when you
knew that your daughter was marrying
such a top class human being you look
that must have a big night for you well
that was a big night but the bigger
night was after when we finally got to
know you before the big night which was
one just without giving too much away
here I kind of knew Gary was a wine
expert when on the very first time we
ever met was at the dinner here in
Manhattan and I came in as a brat about
it and the wine in a brown paper bag and
halfway through the meal when it's my
father Hesburgh you know basically told
me he knew every wine in the world I
said well you know tell me who made this
one when I pull out a bottle then on the
front label said Major League Baseball
it's you know special edition kind of
thing and before without even turning
around the bottle Gary and nailed who
made it and where where it was made and
speaking finally the second meeting was
when I drove up to my home dinner
knew Gary was going to be there for
dinner my daughter and as I drive up to
the house I'm driving up and I see the
identical car I'm driving caller type so
we're this convinced when I walked
inside that Gary rented that car I'll
try to make a good impression buddy it
was his actual car listen thanks for the
time yeah as you can imagine what an
unbelievable you know when you get to
marry someone
you're marrying their family as well and
and and I couldn't have gotten luckier
with Lizzy and her family Peter being at
the forefront of that obviously as my
career took a different change and got
into this corporate marketing world this
is
you know you got to look it up I mean
the guy's got a book I mean I don't know
if it's selling as many copies as the
books that I tend to sell Peter you know
I tend to be a little bit competitive
with this stuff yeah I didn't notice but
what's kind of interesting this is a
book that three of us wrote I came out
in June from McGraw Hill and we did it
for variety reasons I'll just briefly
tell you what it's about
oh no we didn't sell 60 or 70 thousand
pre-sale although it came out in
mid-june and we were told that it's in
its second printing got a kid in early
September
nice chap now we don't know if they
printed 9/11 how many copies but Soviets
in a second listen I think uh so into
you have questions Peter you don't have
questions do you what are you doing here
I but this is like like by the way this
is what's so amazing about you and I
like you look at Peter you're gonna
leave laid out what you were gonna say
this is where we differ quite a bit this
is a difference this is the difference
between the two of us the discipline of
the old or the older generation classic
use piece classic he protects himself
and prepares in advance verse the one
hundred and eighteen percent left brain
dream younger generation Peter I'm
pretty old compared to the people that
are watching just CNN so probably true
yeah look at like a look at these
youngsters how old are you Stefan
Stefan's 24 India India's 25 d-roc Laz
and not too distant future you might
move out of the millennial definition
I'm not in it right now
that's right sucks anyway are you asking
what did you literally bring questions
or can we get into it we can get into
the show we will talk a little more
about the book as I'm here to make sure
the vaynernation by 58 million copies of
it but India India uh let's get into the
show
you ready pk we're both gonna answer for
both gonna answer here all right I mean
we'll play around let's see what happens
here I mean we've wasted we spent a
billion minutes what's that oh you did
India's you know she's sharp she's a
crater left brain 118 percent are good
Kyle asks as someone who's about to turn
30 myself what was the most important
thing you did in your 30s to change your
future
PK once you take that he's about to turn
30 great question and the answer is I
took a deep breath step back and I said
to myself where did I kind of want to be
in the next 10 to 20 years and then I
actually was working at Gillette and I
worked there twice and this was 72 to 78
and I took a step back and I said you
know I wanted that be in a position
between the ages of 32 to 35 where I
could make a decision doing kind of
state corporate America and on a fast
track and doing all those things etc
or shift gears and go into a small
start-up or smaller business environment
had a couple of my own patents so a bit
of an entrepreneurial spirit but it
wasn't in a position where I really had
those choices
wasn't getting inundated by smaller
startups or new ventures and so I took I
said you know what and I love Gillette
they were doing great they bind me and
everything that counted and I said you
know I've got to get into the New York
area where I'll and I made a decision to
move into New York with a large company
who I communicated with and said hey for
three to five years I'm going to beat
the bushes and see if I want to stay or
go into small business and so that's
kind of when I step back I said so Peter
was there because I married Lizzy when I
was 28 turned 29 on our wedding night
and so he saw this which a lot of you
have heard before which is right at 30 I
kind of freaked out a little bit and
started really putting the pedal to the
metal started Wine Library TV right
after it and as much as I worked and as
intensely as I worked in my late 20s 30
started the process of this insanity
that I'm executing against now so I just
I just want to buy the Jets and I didn't
think I was going fast enough
and so I also took a step back and said
where am I going to be in 10 or 20 years
let me make sure my behavior map said so
I think as you're entering the 30s I
think it's really smart to think about
your 40s and 50s so what Gary does on
intuition and gut and heart and passion
I kind of did in Mike over my career
maybe in a little more of a discipline
a little more balanced left-brain
right-brain way and there was a driver
why we decided to write the book thing
to win was to try to bring some very
simple concepts and how to's in the
world of strategy and execution to folks
who are working in small medium large
companies public or private even in the
not-for-profit sector where they can
take a step back and say hey look here
are a few principles a few how to's to
get folks aligned fact-based yeah not
myth based and get aligned on key issues
key opportunities and how do we execute
Yogi Berra who I was a big fan of and
yes I do have a signed picture from Don
Larsen and Yogi Berra because all of you
were curious I'm curious or that who
said a good batter will always be a good
pitcher and vice versa
he is the best believer and good
strategy always drives good execution
and vice versa
yep and that's kind of what this book is
about a more discipline way to kind of
those how to's to what let some power
strategic can work tremendous right hook
Peter
let's go India Ryan asks how do you deal
with drama in the workplace and how do
you avoid having more drama
PK drama in the workplace how much were
you as an executive in corporate America
into HR like stuff or did you kind of
let the pros to handle that oh yeah I
love that area I was into it I was able
Eve that boy I know this guy's fairly as
mr. anal-retentive so me too I kind of
got my fingers dirty I knew when to step
it in a no-return minimus
at the end of the day jargon aside and
I'm a believer with whom you go is more
important than where you go
I got heavily vested on the HR side
because it didn't make any difference
what kind of idea you might have startup
or big company big grand small brands
whatever whatever you're working on
combined with no matter how much capital
you may have working capital from
start-up business or whatever at the end
of the day if you didn't have the right
people in the right team in place you're
dead
game over and I believe that's so much I
don't think there's I don't think
there's any Lakers
there's Kobe and Shaq ii-era and then
there's not and then you know and then
like Stefon who's like a Lakers fan he
then becomes a Golden State Warriors fan
because he's just bandwagon but most
people you know and so I you know we
know I've talked plenty about HR I want
to get this thing moving I want some
speed Indy let's go to next one James
asks banks are old stiff and have
largely the same messaging safety is
their sheer size saving them from
disruption for now yeah I'll jump in on
this one because I'm spending a lot of
time with Silicon Valley that's really
compelling what's going on in Silicon
Valley now with startups that are
looking to attack banks and if you look
at what's going on in general with like
venmo and and so many other things that
we're living through yeah I mean I think
banks have enormous infrastructure and
and have a value prop but there's
enormous amounts of disruption I think
the question alludes to a marketing
message and I think it's actually going
to be more of a utility message when you
start layering you know it's funny
Bitcoin has been not a top of mind of
the startup world recently the
blockchain mentality and just the
innovation around financing and the
financial sector is going to be pretty
aggressive I think that uh I actually
think a lot of banks messages are not
necessarily just about safety I think
it's about you know creating indulgences
and empowering you to do the things that
you want to do I've watched a lot of the
banking messaging as we start planning
on getting into a couple clients in that
sector I think which way more important
is that that banks brands in our society
are very poor because of what happened
with the Wall Street meltdowns and
things of that nature and I think a lot
of banks have been very
load of really properly transition to
mobile and so there's a lot of white
space and a lot of innovation coming
that it's funny I can see the shark
circling around the banking sector and
NSF and they'll be interesting for the
next decade keep it going Alex asks what
do you want to be remembered for the
most right pique um I'll be people be
the best they can be family in other
words it's awesome um for me it's uh
there's a lot of different things I
think about but one of the things that I
I really want to talk a lot about
guilting everybody I ever meet - coming
to my funeral
I'm very passionate about bringing more
value to people than they brought to me
one of the things I admire so much about
my father-in-law Peter is it's scary to
me how many similar different clearly in
certain ways but boy do we have a lot of
similarities and when I started get to
know him it was interesting to me how it
his wife and who's amazing would talk
about him I was like hmm that's like
that's that's me
laughs that's what I like I like that
everybody comes to me for help and I
help them and all those things and so
that's what I would say 5149 that I gave
more to them in our relationship than
they gave to me that said if you agree
with me I think I better reap rethink my
position okay Groucho Marx 1938 duk-soo
next question Peter good news this
audience doesn't even know my $99
donation or Marxist you know you know do
you know Groucho Marx's okay good
Stefan tell the truth no the Iraq no
Peter Peter they didn't even know who
Samantha Fox was oh that's do you know
who smelled the Foxes oh yeah I know
these are generational things yes
Groucho Marx is much more classic I
agree with that is India if you don't
know who Groucho Marx is google him
welcome up Google up let's go on stuff
on Oh
stephane asks Gary you talk about hustle
a lot but what cost did you have to pay
to get here now Peter he worked really
hard um he that's a great I would say at
the end of the day there doesn't have to
be a cause and I really believe that
okay I got everyone's attention you're
talking to a guy who kind of spent a
career at maybe averaging number of
hours say almost six and a quarter to
six and a half days a week
1214 hours average days over an entire
career
having said that you're giving a lot of
insight to why Lizzie is able to deal
with my insanity hero beyond
multitasking and learning how to do our
stuff when you again you take a deep
breath along the way and you step back
on the things that make a difference and
the things that count that you want to
focus on and to me family first so I
always plan I was traveling a lot at my
career was in the consulting business
and I traveled a lot but I always try to
do day trips it back in time for a late
dinner whatever it be there when the
kids took best-managed little league
teams from my son's how was Alex client
as a little league baseball player it
was all defense yes on the record Alex
eat it zone and he was a starter okay um
I I you make time and you try to balance
it out and so I don't know if there were
any real trade-offs on a day-in and
day-out basis doesn't have to be if you
let have focused on solely run your life
there will be usually people family
relationship trails I only believe in
that I think the practical level is that
probably you and I got to spend a little
less but we gave up was our passion for
business or our careers probably came at
the expense of some other potential you
know hobbies and other Leisure's that it
didn't come at the expense of the family
but you may
never developed a golf game or your
tennis game or fishing or other things
that could have been interesting to you
in your life because right I would say
that's that's what I can feel I mean
I've got the Jets so I've got something
thing for me but I definitely art I
would be very interested in all these
other little things but I punt them for
the business point I may or may not be
necessarily relevant I think because
when you again you step back and in
business we make the point in the book
which is by the way think to win this is
the best strategic thinking link like
link that up and boys let's make sure we
link that up is on 23 testimonials is
awesome yeah but that said life personal
business relationships is about making
choices 100% so there's always choices
to be made and if you get your top two
or three priorities right the order of
magnitude of the next level of those
kind of choices maybe we're not as
relevant that's right if you try to be
too much that's right many then you run
into West let me close this with
something that I think will connect with
the audience because it's a truth and
it's and it's something I admire
tremendously I know the student very
well this man's retired but then you
retired
I have fundamental I visit him in
Florida and different things in nature
his retirement Hustle is substantially
stronger than a lot of people that I
knows work ethic in their normal
environment I look at you and I get
pumped because I'm like cool if Peter
can retire like that which means oh I
don't know working all the time maybe I
can retire like that so I appreciate the
air cover
meaning you think I'll lose my
compassion the you've developed the kind
of relationships and networking I am
pleased is that you really believe it
all right
I mean I'm gonna ask you to to ask a
question of the day if you want to ask
this audience entrepreneurs young
Millennials all ages and shapes and
sizes but obviously skewing a little bit
younger than you what kind of question
would you like to ask them to answer in
the comments because I know you love
reading it Peter reads all your comments
he always wants to jump in like rap
this means like you know Sally said you
stink so like he even he's playing
attention boys and girls one thing I
learned over my entire career in
academia as well as in business
especially relative to startup
businesses one to three year old
businesses working on big brands at big
companies etc was at the end of the day
it came down to two or three words that
I would always ask when anyone brought
in an idea for a new ad campaign a new
product new consumer promotion idea a
new opportunity within a company small
medium or large and came down to two or
three words and if they could answer the
question for these two or three words
that went together by the way and I'll
tell you right now the middle word was
and so you only need two more what would
be your two words that you think every
successful business needs to be able to
address blank and blank I like it yeah
well sue me yes Center is not blank
got it Peter I love you Cheers gonna
kiss good you can fasiqun questions
we'll keep answering them
[Music]